[Music]
boy howdy hi this is a toughy ye-yes
here are you practicing a little salute
huh yes you are we'll take care of that
won't we this is so much harder than I
thought oh that makes two of us all
right Oh God
that's why you're such a little bastard
no one's ever changed you yeah you got a
big stinky in there don't you gotta
sounds like Hitler's anus which which
would make sense wouldn't it yeah I
think we both know I don't have what it
takes to do this so I'm just gonna
change her diaper real quick and then
I'm gonna come back with my friend cable
he loves killing you hey everybody it's
Charlie so we got to talk about new
Deadpool we found out that Tim Miller
was going to use the Fantastic Four in
his version so I'll explain what that
deleted scene was if you're new to the
channel there's a new round of that
blu-ray giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on the video uh name a new
winner at the end of this the Hitler
scene is just a play on the most asked
question about time travel when talking
about morality would you go back and
kill Hitler if you had a time machine so
it's a moral question but it's also a
broader question about the butterfly
effect would killing Hitler in the past
lead to something even worse because of
something that we can't conceive of
because of the butterfly effect
they've already answered that question
several times over on the flash when you
try to alter the timeline to avoid some
crazy future outcome time we'll find a
way to replace that event with something
even worse I want you not to mess with
the timeline dr. wells if you would just
let me tell you what was gonna happen
you'd understand why I did this whatever
tragedy you think you've just averted
time will find a way to replace it and
trust me Barry
the next one
could be much worse they cut the scene
during test screenings because they felt
like it was too big of a bummer to send
the movie I don't like Deadpool killing
a baby even though it was baby Hitler
people were like this is just too much
of a bummer to go out on like they
wanted to end it on that Green Lantern
kill you're welcome Canada just because
that was kind of funny like making fun
of Green Lantern is pretty safe for a
Deadpool movie god damn that's beautiful
you're welcome I didn't know about the
second tag at the very end of the
credits though where he realizes that he
can't do it the joke there being that
he's gonna go get cable to do it because
cable loves killing people the whole
plot of the movie is about cable going
back into the past to alter the timeline
by prematurely killing Julian Denison's
fire fist character so that he can't do
something terrible in the future which
is exactly what Deadpool was trying to
do in this Hitler scene but you all want
to know about the deleted Fantastic Four
scene so this is actually pretty crazy
we just found out that in the Tim Miller
version of Deadpool 2 before he left the
project there were a couple different
characters that he wanted to use and the
plot of the movie was a little bit
different it felt a little bit different
the character designs were a little bit
different so I'll talk about the biggest
changes but the whole thing with the
Fantastic Four is that he was gonna have
Colossus go to Yancy Street fight Ben
Grimm so it sounds like he was mostly
hyping up Colossus versus the thing but
there were character designs for the
entire cast of Josh Trank's Fantastic
Four you have the miles teller mr.
fantastic you have Michael B Jordans
Human Torch so I think there are a
couple reasons why that didn't end up
happening like you can see why Fox might
not want to remind people about that
Fantastic Four movie it's really
expensive to do all those characters
because they would have had to do all
this CG he wanted to do a very
comic-book
accurate version of the thing the way we
found out about this was through the
concept artist that was working with Tim
Miller to develop these scenes and he
said the Tim Miller was very picky about
the character models I think a little
bit of it also had to do with the
Fantastic Four actor's signing off on
that like could you imagine them going
to Michael B Jordan asking them to
include his character in this movie
right after Black Panther
come out I'm standing in your house
serving justice to a man who stole your
vibranium and murdered your people just
as your teen couldn't deliver one of the
best Marvel characters and Marvel
villains overall in the entire Marvel
Cinematic Universe of any big superhero
film kill monger was amazing so it's
crazy to think about his Fantastic Four
performance after you watch Black
Panther even the actor himself when he
was on stage at Comic Con a couple years
ago when they announced the Black
Panther movie and brought them on stage
like hey we're getting ready to shoot
this it's gonna be really cool one of
his comments was it's great to finally
be in the good Marvel Universe which was
like the biggest backhand to Fox's
Marvel movies at the time but now that
the Disney deals going through it's all
coming back around hopefully they'll
have some fun with the idea that both
Chris Evans and Michael B Jordan have
now played two different Marvel
characters in really really big movies
even though obviously Fantastic Four
totally bombed that feels like something
you would do in a Deadpool movie like
legit MCU Fantastic Four will probably
be more serious
even though Marvel films in general tend
to have a lot of humor they don't get
quite as meta as Deadpool does with
those in jokes like making fun of all
the continuity problems usually it just
winds up being more spider-man making
pop-culture references it's all about to
tense off to save the universe look
dance-off it's not it's not it's not I
can still move exactly like photos is it
still the greatest movie in history it
never was
don't encourage this alright we're
getting no help from Flash Gordon here
Flash Gordon by the way that's a
compliment
no more pop-culture references from you
on this trip I think it would have been
an opportunity to make them feel like
they were actually pretty cool like you
put them in a Deadpool movie you have a
really badass fight with the things so
you turn him into a cool character but
you also Lampoon him with a whole bunch
of jokes and talk about how ridiculous
he is as a character so it's like the
same thing the Deadpool does with
Colossus on a regular basis like they
turn Colossus into a pretty cool
character but at every opportunity
Deadpool makes fun of him and points out
how ridiculous he is we can't allow this
Deadpool please come close yeah big
chrome
it's not nice for me trust me that
wheezing bag of dick tips has it coming
the entire movie is Deadpool making fun
of all the other characters so you would
have had to imagine that there would be
a version of that with the Fantastic
Four in this the big thing about Yancy
Street is that it's a big comic book
location specific to the Ben Grimm
character it's down here on the Lower
East Side it's the location of the Yancy
Street gang it's like right around the
Williamsburg Bridge here they used to
torment him when he was younger then
they popped up later in the comics
during the fear itself storyline when
Odin's brother cold Boursin took over
Asgard and sent all the hammers down to
earth to create the worthy one of the
hammers fell to Yancy Street and
transform Ben Grimm into angrier breaker
of souls so Yancy Street is just a
really big Fantastic Four comic book
location so it would have been really
cool but you can see how doing like a
whole extra scene with this big fight
would have been crazy expensive the
movie was already really expensive and
one of the things that makes the
Deadpool character works so well is that
they do it so cheaply making fun of
those big-budget superhero films like
infinity war or any of the big DC films
now that the Disney deal is going
through I think the next time we do see
Fantastic Four it'll be legit one of
those characters will pop up in a Marvel
movie I've already done a couple of
videos about what they plan to do with
Deadpool and those characters so I'll
link that video at the end of this I'm
working on a new Avengers Illuminati
video so I'll post that next should be
up in the next couple of hours but
congratulations to the giveaway winner
from my last big video Arwa el Moussa
please email me on the back end of my
channel so I can get your contact
details click here for that new Avengers
4 titled teaser and click here tour and
what Marvel's plans are for Deadpool in
Fantastic Four during phase 4 and phase
5 thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight
[Music]